meanwhile the FDA is fast tracking
methods of fighting this coronavirus
outbreak the most recent being a test
that can detect kovat 19 antibodies in
just two minutes
let's bring an FDA Commissioner dr.
Stephen Hahn on that mr. commissioner
and dr. Hahn good morning to you and
thank you for being here Thank You
Sandra - a pleasure to be here we have
so many questions for you first I'll
start on that on that note the
two-minute coronavirus test is it
effective so if you're referring to the
test that is been said to be available
for antibody testing that is can you
detect someone who now has immunity
against it we are not authorizing those
tests we are in the process of looking
at applications for those tests and
obviously that's a huge priority but
just the point it's not a diagnostic
test it doesn't tell you whether you
actually have the disease right now with
tests that's been advertised as one that
tells you whether you've been exposed to
it and have antibodies we're working
very hard to further develop to further
work with developers over these tests to
get as many of them out because they are
a component of the public health effort
some say that that test would be key
though because then you have healthy
people walking around with no symptoms
who may be carrying the virus and could
expose more vulnerable people like
pregnant women or the elderly so do you
see that as an absolute necessity as far
as priority for the FDA to get that
approved there is no question that this
is a priority for FDA we issued some
regulatory flexibility guidance
several weeks ago regarding this and
test developers are allowed to develop
them without pre market authorization so
in other words they don't have to come
to us first we're very happy to look at
their data and information but again I
want to stress to you that this is a
complementary test to the diagnosis if
for example you have antibodies to the
virus that is an immune response it
doesn't mean that you're currently
affected so it goes hand in hand with
the diagnostic test of looking at
whether you actually have the virus
currently present because that gets to
your issue of whether someone is
infectious
okay so on that note we just saw across
a moment ago that the FDA has announced
the coronavirus treatment acceleration
program so where do we stand as far as
discovering treatments and advancing
them and improving them from the FDA
this is a great news for the American
people in terms of the partnership
between the private sector and
government for the last four to six
weeks we stood up a group to actually
look at the acceleration of potential
therapies treatments for coronavirus
starting with the agents that actually
specifically treat the virus and also
something called convalescent plasma
where we're looking at again
gathering these antibodies to give to
people who are sick to treat them so
this is a cross-agency effort that's a
complete partnership with the private
sector we're streamlining all processes
to make sure that we can get the
applications that come to us into the
the treatment arena and the hospitals as
quickly as possible
Sandra it's really important to stress
that there are no FDA approved therapies
for kovin 19:00 but what we're talking
about is expediting getting potentially
positive therapies therapies that could
help out into hospitals into doctors
hands typically under the setting of a
clinical trial where we can generate the
evidence and the data that helps FDA
make the decisions about the safety and
effectiveness of treatments and we're
pushing that forward very aggressively I
think it's fair to say you sound pretty
optimistic as far as progress on that is
concerned I'll read you a headline from
The Washington Post because in the
middle of all this there's a lot of
criticism of the FDA possibly going too
quickly with some of these treatments
and potentially potentially not looking
at all the risks involved and rather
looking at just trying to get fast help
the FDA authorizes widespread use of
unproven drugs to treat coronavirus
saying possible benefit outweighs the
risk
this particular piece goes into the
combination of those drugs and says that
health experts are warning that the well
known side effects could become
commonplace with widespread use in
particular looking at people that
already have existing health problems
heart problems taking certain drugs
antidepressants and that these could
become fatal so are you seeing the
benefits outweigh the potential risks of
exposing people to these treatments this
is a really important issue and I want
to explain it we issued an emergency use
authorization just as described in that
article for entry of hydroxychloroquine
and chloroquine into the system we did
not approve it for the use of treatment
of covin 19:00 but what this allowed us
to do is have donated drug to come into
the system that drug will be allocated
for clinical trials where we'll be able
to ask the question about whether these
drugs work that's the best way to get
the data and the science for us to tell
Americans whether this is the right drug
for them it's also allowed the donated
drug to come into the circulation
because the other way that Americans
have the potential to get this drug is
to go to their doctor know about the
risks and benefits with a doctor have a
discussion about the drug and decide
whether it's the right drug for them to
take we have not taken a stance nor we
on whether doctors should prescribe it
we're providing facts and information
about the risks and benefits but that
really is and should be a doctor-patient
decision where do we stand as far as
ventilators are concerned we hear a lot
of mixed messaging on the need for those
ventilators we've also heard from the
governor of New York State talking about
now the need for some of these hospitals
to put two patients on one ventilator
what is the FDA recommending on that and
are we are we where we need to be as far
as having the capacity to administer
those ventilators to the patients that
need them well the good news here is
that FEMA and Health and Human Services
are working very hard to increase
capacity I'll tell you what FDA's role
is again FDA does not regulate the
practice of medicine we provide guidance
about what's the best way to expand the
capacity what's the best way to actually
clean these ventilators what's the best
way to help manufacturers ramp up so
that we get the best devices in the
hands of providers our job is to make
sure that devices drugs whatever we're
talking about are safe and effective so
we've provided a lot of guidance and
flexibility around this so that we
expand capacity and then we're feeding
that information up to Health and Human
Services in FEMA as they look at the
allocation and the ramp up in the
manufacturing well we hear the need for
them and a lot of companies have tried
to fill that void Ford and other other
motor companies have stepped in and
tried to use their manufacturing
facilities to make those ventilators
really appreciate your time this morning
mr. Commissioner please come back soon
Thank You sandy really appreciate your
time thank you